let's bring you more on that breaking
news now that Connor Burns has been
fired as trade Minister following
allegations of inappropriate
behavior we can bring in Sky
correspondent Nick Martin who's at
Westminster uh for us hello to you Nick
a number 10 spokesperson has said he's
been fired following a complaint of
serious misconduct it doesn't sound good
what more do you know
well we know what the Conor Burns has
been quite a a quiet but influential
figure in government for the last few
years although it's fair to say that he
hasn't been a sort of big headline
Grabber so many many people watching may
not have even heard of him but
nevertheless he was one of Boris
Johnson's closest allies during his
Premiership and he was in fact one of
his closest friends we know that for the
last few weeks of Boris Johnson's Rocky
life as prime minister Connor Burns was
very close to his side in the bunker
trying to sort of uh strategize a way
out of Boris Johnson's problems and for
a time he was Northern Ireland Minister
and he had a lot to do with trying to
thrash out the problems connected to the
Northern Ireland protocol post-brexit
now under Liz truss he was a trade
Minister
um
carrying out various rules in that job
we know that he was at the Conservative
Party Conference last week but now we
under understand that he's had the whip
removed this is what number 10 say today
they say following a complaint of
serious misconduct the Prime Minister
has asked Conor Burns MP to leave the
government with immediate effect the
Prime Minister took direct action on
being informed of this allegation and it
is clear that all ministers should
maintain the high standards of behavior
as the public rightly expects the whips
office have also made comment about this
they say the spokesman said we have
suspended the whip pending investigation
into allegations of inappropriate
behavior earlier this week we take all
such allegations extremely seriously the
Prime Minister has been clear that the
highest standards in public life must be
upheld so it's obvious although we don't
know the details that something is
alleged to have taken place that's
caught the attention via a complaint of
the Prime Minister the office of number
10 and also the whips office and Connor
Burns so as I say has been a quiet but
influential figure within the government
for the last few years closely aligned
with Boris Johnson took a seat in Liz
truss's um in in Liz truss's
Administration has now had the whip
removed removed and more more no doubt
will come out about what the allegations
are but quite a significant departure
for Liz truss
um Connor Burns there having the rip
removed he's effectively lost his job in
government